this is it  this looks very much it yeah yeah  the alireza  not shining in classical chess here for  so far for the third event in a row  he gave us a glimpse in the wrapping  blitz destroying everybody  but today  i know i haven't checked with the  computer it looked like he was he had to  suffer  a little bit from the start and never  quite shook it off no well he got this  this ending which we i think correctly  evaluated as very unpleasant yeah  and um  he didn't really generate my chance  right  it was probably possible to do it better  than he did  yeah he just waited and then there's  just no hope  [Music]  and he does resign  king f7  the dagger  yeah it's a remarkably dominant final  position for this sort of level  yeah you rarely see this